Hey, guys!
Hey, how are you?
Where are you heading to?
We're going to Charlotte.
Do you mind if I ask you a couple of questions?
I won't take much of your time.
Sure.
Come on, sit down.
Have you ever had the feeling that something was missing,...
...like when you leave your house in the morning...
...and you feel like there's something you're forgetting,...
...that feeling that there's something more that you should be doing,...
...somewhere else you should be?
And you have to do something, but you never know exactly what?
Have you ever felt that?
Yeah.
Maybe.
If I told you there's a place where you will find the answers to these questions,...
...where you will find yourself surrounded by mountains, jungles and the ocean,...
...would you like to go?
Yes.
Okay.
Of course!
Open the suitcase.
Are you kidding?
Is this a joke?
No.
What?
Congratulations!
You're going to Peru!
Seriously?
I won a trip to Peru!
Oh my god!